I started, you know when I started eating for breakfast? Just almonds. That's it. Just almonds? Just almonds. That's it. Literally. Yep. Are you really eating just almonds for breakfast? Yeah, just almonds and then maybe a yogurt thing. Okay, well so now it's also a yogurt thing. Might want to take the just off the top of that. Welcome to Smartless. Smart Less Smart Less
Smart Less Smart Less Smart Less Smart Less
Smart Hey, Cool Dad, Cool Dad, you got the long sleeve shirt on underneath the short sleeve shirt today, huh? Very 90s. It's a very, it's a cold day for, um... So then why don't you just wear a long sleeve golf shirt? No, I don't have a long sleeve golf shirt. So I have this and I have, and if I want to I can take it out.
Why don't you wear your short sleeve golf shirt and just put a sweater over the top of it instead of doing the cool dad thing. I am, I've got a sweater and I'm gonna have a shell because it's kinda rainy and it's very unusually cold for Los Angeles. That's really nice. And I'm teeing off at 12.30. Wait, Tracy bought you both golf shirts.
She did? Yeah, they're here at the house. Oh great. Love her. Did she buy you anything? She did, yes. Driving gloves for the golf cart? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. She joined me and she got me a new set of clubs. So I'll see you guys later. You don't want to know who I'm playing with today. I'm surprised you didn't ask me. Paul. You're playing with Paul. Paul.
You're playing with Paul. I'm playing Paul, but guess who else? Who you got? You got Paul, our buddy from Toronto. Paul M. we'll call him. Paul Michaelis. And. we'll call him. Paul Michaelis. And then we'll have...
I got a real friend of the show. Danny Dees. Danny Dees. Danny Dees. I love him. The nicest man and the greatest guy ever in finance. Yes, sure. In many categories.
And then our JB, our buddy. You're going to play five, huh? Football legend. Gareth Bale. Gareth's in town. in many categories. And then, our JB, our buddy, football legend, Gareth Bale, Gareth Sinton. You're gonna play five today? Yeah. No, it's me and Paul, Dan and Gareth. Oh, sorry, I'm not great with math. Evidently.
So I'm very excited, I'm doing a home game today, recording from Los Angeles for the first time in a while. It feels nice, I've got a microphone on a stand now, instead of a, I'm not comfortable with the New York setup. What if you came home, you've been away for a couple weeks, and then you just looked around, you just started to notice some of my stuff was there. Yeah, your underwear's in the sauna.
That would be awful. That's disgusting. And you just notice like Amanda's wearing like an oversized shirt to bed, and you're like, is that Will's shirt? Well, you know what, we're about a minute from that. I know. Well guys, before I get into my guest here,
can we just, I heard something recently, a description of a podcast that, you know, we'll never be lucky enough to have a description like this, I think. It's a show about people with more balls than a bowling alley. You know, like, no one- That's Knoxville said that.
He said you have to have that. Knoxville said, right, Knoxville said, it's called Pretty Sure I Can Fly. Pretty sure I can fly, yeah, yeah, yeah. The Johnny Knoxville host that. He said that. Knoxville said that, right. Knoxville said it's called Pretty Sure I Can Fly. Yeah, yeah, yeah. The giant Knoxville host with Elna Baker. From This American Life. From This American Life. It's about, yeah, these people that do things
that have far more courage than the three of us put together would ever even dream of having. Well, thanks a lot. Right, and unlike ours, Pretty Sure I Can Fly is educational and inspiring. Exactly. Yeah, you're not going to learn a whole lot here, but we hide it right there in the title. Yeah, it's a great podcast. Yeah, it's worth checking out.
Anyway, Pretty Sure I Can Fly by Smartless Media is out now with Johnny Knoxville and Elna Baker. So punch it into your nearest podcast playing machine and enjoy. Yeah. All right. Huge apologies to our guests. This has been much too long here for the Regis and Kathie Lee chatter. Here comes our guest.
Sadly, even though I'm in Los Angeles, I still have not written an intro. Mostly though because I just love this guy. I don't need to write an intro for him. I know him. He's a buddy of mine. I think he's a buddy of both of yours as well, but I'm closer with him, okay?
I'm a big, big fan of his work. He's an enormous movie star, global, and even just bigger, all-time great guy, he's got some interesting things to tell us. I know you're gonna love this hour. Everybody, ladies and gentlemen, it's Hollywood's Jeremy Renner. Jeremy, come on out.
There he is. Look at him go! Hollywood's Jeremy Renner. What's going on? This guy's a major movie star. You guys better tighten it up. Look at that. What's happening?
What's up, man? I wish we were all together, actually. I know, right? I haven't seen some faces on the screen, but it's nice to hear you guys. Jeremy, you know where we're all together? Right here. Right here in the heart.
I didn't see where you were pointing. Yeah, no, my breasts. I had to reboot my computer right before we started. All my questions are gone, but that's okay. Oh, I can start, I can start. No, yeah, you go. No, I go, yeah. Yeah, Jer, first of all.
Welcome. Yeah, welcome, you look great. Look at the guns already. The guns, baby. of all, welcome. You look great, look at the guns already. The guns. I mean, crazy. You're looking great. I follow you on Instagram as well and I love all your positivity.
Wait, what, really? Yeah, I love all the positive comments. You're always so warm and thankful and grateful to your fans and everybody with all the support, with all the tragedy that you've had. And you're doing so great. It's so good to see you. Well yeah, you're busy.
Mayor of Kingstown's out now, right? Started June 2nd, I think, yes? They're on the camera. Coming out June 2nd, yeah. Well when this airs, it'll be out. So unbelievable start to the season there, Jeremy. Yeah, way to go. June 2nd, when back on June 2nd, the show came out.
Yeah. Season three. The first time I ever saw you, I just moved to Los Angeles, and I don't know if you'd like, we can cut this if you don't wanna talk about it, but I watched this reality show called The It Factor. It Factor, yeah.
And it was like one of the first reality shows ever, and you were one of the actors, they followed around to auditions and see about your career. And I loved the series and I had another friend in it as well. And I remember you getting Dahmer or something, playing Jeffrey Dahmer and then, or Swat, and you had a pick between the two or one of the two.
And I was like, oh my God, this guy's gonna be so huge. And we're watching it in real time, you going on auditions and really going Yeah, that was a really random random thing I actually end up doing that show because I did Domber already and we shot we shot that movie in two weeks for like $100,000 so you didn't know what was gonna happen with this tiny little movie So I did it to kind of promote that yeah but then in it turned into like this little Cinderella story
because that movie came out and then I got like, William Morris, all these things happened. And then, like you said, the audition for SWAT and all these other movies started coming as like this sort of Cinderella story for a breaking actor in Hollywood. Yeah, and that we watched it with, like we were out long for the ride with you.
It was really cool. I don't know that anybody would do that today. Do you think anybody, that show would work? I don't know, it'd be hard to kind of catch that. Does anybody know when you're gonna break or have any sort of, right? Yeah, but I mean, think about all those things over the years where they've tried to like
get behind the scene or whatever, but to actually, to actually lock on to somebody, to an actor, and then have it pay off and actually become a big movie. The odds are pretty rare. And then like months later, it was like Jeremy Renner, you were this huge star and have remained since, so it was really exciting.
You know, our buddy Sam Jones did a great documentary on Wilco called... Trying to Break Your Heart. Trying to Break Your Heart, yeah. Where the cameras were with Wilco while they were making Yankee Hotel Foxtrot or Foxtrot Hotel, whatever it is. And the label dropping them
because it was too challenging to listen to and then they went to a different label or made their own, I can't remember. But then it ends up winning the Grammy for best album of the year, I think. And I couldn't believe that cameras were there for that whole thing. Sounds like this is similar.
Yeah, yeah, you catch a little lightning in a bottle. Yeah, but building off of that, Jeremy, I mean, buddy, watching your career just explode right out of the gate and it has not stopped yet. I mean. Well, first of all, Hurt Locker was just phenomenal. Yeah. And everything you've done since,
but that was like the thing, I remember just watching that and being like, who's this fucking dude is? Who's this motherfucker, he's taking all of our jobs. He's just crushing. Were you always so discerning from an early age in your career
to be able to pick what gave you the strength to say no to certain things and not freak out about your paycheck and your rent? Yeah, yeah, I think that, I don't know where exactly that comes from, I know for me, it was being very clear and focused on what I wanted and also what I didn't want. Early on, I had to do a lot of comedy stuff and I'm like, oh my God, it wasn't trying to go down
that road and I ended up, it wasn't trying to go down that road. And I ended up, that's why Domino is a great turning point for me, to kind of go into darker, sort of deeper, sort of character roles. And I just was just kind of clear. And then if I didn't connect to it, there's an easy no, no matter how much money.
I've turned down more money than I'll ever make in life. Because I never did something for money. That's great. And you have to be okay with yourself in that. In order to say no to money, and mind you, I mean, I think even during that It Factors show, I was turning down a lot of money and I had no power, I had no running freaking water.
I thought you meant Hollywood power. But I'm living on $5 a month to eat. Like it's Yum Yum Donuts, you get like 13 donut holes, 14 donut holes for 99 cents, I'm crushing those for two weeks. And donut hole a day, it's like, it's brutal, dude. But you know that when you know your limits, right? You know you're allowing yourself to go,
it's like, all right, well, I don't have to say yes to something just for money. And so it gives me the power and the balls to say, to note things. I love that. And then Clint Barton comes along, you're like, how much? Well, it wasn't that much. I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
So Heart Locker happens, you get the Academy Award nomination, and is there then a waterfall of really great options for you that become somewhat problematic because you can't do them all? How do you go about picking through all the great stuff you're looking at then after that? I feel like the calendar filled up pretty quickly.
I don't know. What was next, was the town next? There's a town, yeah, was next. And there's Mission Impossible. And there's Mission Impossible. Then Avengers was booked, but it was shot later, and then it was born, and then it was, there's Hansel and Gretel,
and then there's Mission Impossible. So it was like, all that happened probably within six months, so they're all, for the most part, franchises, if you will, so I'm kind of booked up. And so they all got scheduled, so your next, basically your three, four years, five years is booked. Yeah, it was like four years was jammed up. I was gone for four years.
Wow. And how did you deal with that, with being away from home, living out of a suitcase, I mean, that's a, and all the fame too. Like, that transition, talk to us about that. Well, it's actually interesting, because I was kind of very excited to have the opportunities and by the time, born was the last thing
that kind of came my way, and I'd already signed on to Avengers. That's now, you know, how many a decade of your life, you have to sign on for it. Doesn't mean you're gonna do it, but you sign on for it, right? I'm gonna be 50 years old and fucking tights. Right.
So that's what I was having my conversation with with the team, right? So I'm like, am I doing this? Am I really doing this? And then same with Mission Impossible. You know, I talk with Tom, he's like, all right, well, we're gonna do three of these. I'm like, okay, well, there's,
so my whole decade's booked, for the most part, right? And then Bourne comes around, and he's like, all right, well, we're gonna do three of these. I'm like, okay, well, that's... So my whole decade's booked for the most part, right? And then Born comes around and was like, oh, wow, I really creatively obviously love to do this. I love to be involved with Matt, what he did with it. But I had to really pause and say, let me think about this here. I'm kind of jammed up already. And this is also on the face of the thing too, kind of different than Mission Impossible,
it's much more Tom and this type of thing. So it was a quick 24 hours sort of thinking session on it, but I had to take pause on it. And all of that's very exciting, but I knew I gave up a decade of my life. Yeah. And Jeremy, were you worried that when you make these decisions, did you ever go down? but I knew I gave up a decade of my life. And yeah, and Jeremy, were you worried that when you make these decisions, did you ever go down there?
Because I wonder if I would go like, yeah, today I want to do it, but how am I going to feel five years from now if I'm locked in? We don't know that. We don't know those things. You can consider it, right? That's all you can do is consider it. You're an idiot to say no To these things they're amazing opportunities are all quality Franchises if you will at what cost yeah at what cost it will be something all that we determined later You know yeah, and I and I knew is gonna miss a lot But I knew that there was an end to it right yeah, and that's so I can like let me go
Let me let me give it a go. And yeah, don't get me wrong, there were times where, most of the time it was amazing. Most of the time it was really great. But then there was like, you know. You hadn't become a dad yet, right? Yeah, I wasn't a dad yet. So that's why I can have a really good time. I was a single guy, I can just go out
and just focus on work and see the world, right? And get paid to be in shape and all these amazing things, right, it was fantastic. But I did miss my family, right, that I'm very deeply close with, it's very large. And so I had like four birthdays in a row with my assistant, who's, I'm on January 7th, and he was January 8th,
and he's exactly a decade younger than me. So we just celebrated our birthdays together like in a Ferrari in Abu Dhabi. I mean you know that's an episode of Will and Grace or something. Yeah we actually shot it. I don't know but it's a it was a great thing but you don't know what's what's what I'll come down the road it's a wonderful blessings and you know the perspective to take from that I do the same thing all over again. I don't have the energy to do it now. But the schedule of those huge, huge films with a lot
of stunts and special effects, the budget on those allows for a much slower movement, a pacing as far as knocking down pages each day. Was that a big transition for you coming from, even I would imagine the Hurt Locker was something that was not as highly budgeted as these things. What is that like, that snails pace? Because sometimes on those stunt films,
like Mission Impossible, the degree of difficulty is just astronomical and the stunt complexity and stuff where you're only shooting like, you know, what the audience sees is maybe 10 seconds, it might take you a week to shoot that. How do you keep? Or three weeks, yeah, yeah. Like in Mission Impossible, like that,
the whole Burj Khalifa. How do you keep your focus and whatnot during that? Well, initially I think the main difference is just craft services. Yeah. It's a bit different. Yeah, nice trailer. It's in the trailer side. But yeah, it does take longer.
But a lot of it is like in the prep too for anything that's physical. When it's those physical movies, there's so much, you know, it's months and months of physical prep before you go do it. So then while you're doing it, you're training like an athletic team or an athletic sport. And you have to treat it such. What was your favorite way in which to get in shape?
Were you into the boxing? Were you into cardio? Were you into just cross training? I'm sure it's been a bunch of things. You've been in shape for a long time. I think it depends on what the role really requires. Most of them, for instance, like, for instance, like the Born Legacy, that required the most physical.
And so we had to train like all sorts of mixed martial arts and judo and just all the different things, man. It's home- So you get like, have those like training mishaps where you end up getting clocked in the face by the guy or you clock somebody in the face while you're. I might have smashed a dude or two. Now, when you go over to something like American Hustle
or Arrival is that it must be nice where you don't have to wait around for a bunch of stunt stuff and effect stuff and you're doing much more sort of, well it's a different kind of acting on those films. Yeah, did you love that transition? Yeah, well I mean it's just sort of, that's kind of more in the decision making to do the job.
Those are the easy ones with great directors and great writing and great characters. You can go in with a lot more cerebral, much more emotional context characters and a lot more people to work with. And the other ones like from the Avengers and Bourne and all those Mission Possibles, there's, it's much more about the stunts
and the physical stuff. Which is fun, it's just a different muscle to use. And ideally you're sort of switching back and forth, right? I think so, I mean to keep it all interesting, right, I'm on the third season of Mirror Kingstown, right, I've never done that before, repeated the same character, you've done an Ozark and you've done shit most of your life. And the pace of that though is much faster, right?
Oh, it's nuts, right. That's enjoyable that there's momentum, yeah? Yeah, yeah, it's something interesting about it, it's like a controlled chaos in like In television today, especially, you know, we're shooting If you shoot like a film like a 10-hour film and a third of the time, you know, it's crazy We'll be right back This episode is brought to you in part by liquid IV guys, it's almost like 90 degrees this weekend
It's getting hot, it's summertime. Everybody's gonna be sweating and thirsty and dehydrated. That's why we need Liquid IV. We're made of 60 to 70% water, so when we're dehydrated, we feel imbalanced. You know the signs, fogginess, fatigue, that kind of just like yucky feeling. A single stick of Liquid IV delivers superior hydration
with three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink, plus eight vitamins and nutrients. It's hydration for physical endurance, mental clarity, and overall well-being. It's no mystery why they're the number one powdered hydration brand in America. I was filming Three Stooges back in 2010, 11,
something like that, and we filmed in Atlanta, Georgia, and it was like 110 degrees every single day for like three months. Had I had Liquid IV, I would have skated right through it with no problem. They didn't have anything like that back then. I wish, wish, wish they did. When I go to the beach,
I always bring like a pack of Liquid IV, and it always works. It always gets me through. It makes me feel so much better because I know I'm hydrated with Liquid IV. Turn your ordinary water into extraordinary hydration. With Liquid IV, get 20% off your first order of liquid IV when you go to liquid IV comm and use code smartless at checkout
That's 20% off your first order when you shop better hydration today using promo code smartless at liquid IV comm The show is sponsored by better help This year's gone by so quickly already. It's already like a little past midway of 2024. And something I'm super, super proud of is my relationship with Scotty, 18 years. Can you believe it? 18. So I still want to work on it and make it even better every single year.
And so just lucky that way that I found somebody to go through life with like that. And when life goes so fast, it's important to take a moment to celebrate your wins and make adjustments for the rest of the year. Therapy can help you take stock of your progress and set achievable goals for the next six months. And if you recently listened to Smartless, you know I'm obsessed with setting goals and goalposts for yourself to hit.
If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Take a moment. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartList today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. This episode of SmartList is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. So in our home, whenever we watch a movie, we have little tiny candy jars, right? And each one we have different brands of candies. And what we did with one of them was empty out some of the chocolate and we put Skinny Pop in there.
For real. So I grabbed a little handful of these treats, a little handful of these treats, and then like a big bowl of skinny pop out of the skinny pop jar. Is that weird? I don't think so. Skinny Pop Original Popcorn is delicious,
and it's made with just three simple ingredients. I love that. In addition to their original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors ranging from cheddar jalapeno to sweet and salty kettle. Shop Skinny Pop now. And now back to the show. How were you able to struggle through the really outrageously poor direction from a
guy like Ben Affleck? How did you get through the town? It's just a miracle the results that end up on the screen on his films Was it? Well, just just walk us through it. Yeah. Yeah, he's great, man He's great. I remember meeting with Ben on that I didn't that's first time I met him I'm like how I think my first meeting with it with him sitting across the mic How my first question to him was like, how are you gonna direct this thing,
and act, and star in it? I mean, you're kinda okay actor, I mean, how are you expected to direct and act this thing? Kinda fuckin' with him. He's cool, he's, you know, Ben. He's a beast, it's humble. He's just so good. And he's so damn smart, man.
Working with him was so, so great. And I really learned how, I mean, he gave me so much freedoms. I mean, he says, we're not gonna do dialects. I've never been to Boston in my life. Yeah. Don't know anything about it, right? And he's like, we're not gonna do any dialect coaches.
I'm like, okay, great. What the fuck am I gonna do then? I'm like, all right, he introduced me to a bunch of people that just got out of prison. Had a bunch of armed robbers and all that shit, bank robbers, so I just hung out with these guys in the bars for a couple weeks in town. And then I kind of found the character
and found what I was gonna do. Oh, that's cool. No way. That's cool. Yeah, yeah, so it was, but if we didn't shoot in Boston, I would have been royally screwed. Yeah.
But thank God, thank God we were there, because all of my access to what I needed was there. And then he just wanted to, he's so smart, and he just kind of let me do my thing, and at first he would start to mouth my lines as I was acting with him. Jeez. And I'm like, I had to turn my head,
I'm like, I'm gonna smash this motherfucker. I'm gonna smash this fucker. But only pissed me off, they'd get me more in the mood with this guy. But it was like the very first scene we shot. And I don't think he did it after that anymore. But yeah, he was great, man. He really was so great.
He was working his butt off, man. And, but I really was, I fell in love with him and have so much respect for him. He's just one of the smartest guys I know, actually. He's really, really smart. You know what's funny? You watch those movies, specifically those Boston movies,
and if you ask people from Boston one of the things that they hate, and you guys did such a good job in that movie. Such a good job. And I've talked about this with Matt before, too. You watch other movies where people do Boston accents and I'm not gonna name them because there are a lot of really big names, really famous actors
who've done big Boston movies and the accents are fucking terrible. And people from Boston hate it. They get pissed off. And if these people had any idea, and I'm talking big shiny names. You come in and they fucking- Tell us what one of the names sounds like.
It sort of rhymes with... Dude, dude, let me say this, dude. You're not gonna get me fucking classic, baby, trying to get me to say something about these fucking... No. You know what? I used to work for fucking Dead and Fire Department. My brother works for fucking Edison.
Shut the fuck up, dude. Nah, fuck you. Wait, Jeremy, how did you become Jeremy Renner, the guy we know today? Going back to the first thing we talked about today, when I was like, oh my God, I watched you, and you coming up and you had all this kind of chutzpah to just wanna be great and not worry about anything else
but the art of it, where did that come from? Were you a kid that was inspired by something? I gotta say, Sean, you've got a lot of hudspud to use the word hudspud. Yeah, with the extra hudspud. Where do you get, I mean, you know. Johnny Whitebread over here. Go ahead, Jeremy.
Fire department. I had a, I didn't really discover acting until I was in college. Really? Oh, really? Yeah, yeah, and in theater. So I went in with a criminology sort of idea I was gonna study or computer science or some shit and then took an elective.
And I think I told you, I might have mentioned this to you Jason, when we had dinner at Downey's, but I saw an elective when I was signing up for the courses and acting was one of them. I'm like, I'll do this speech class, I'll try this acting thing. The only thing that popped in my brain, what I knew about acting was Michael J. Fox
and fucking you, Jace, right? Because he shows these fucking family ties and all these goddamn, just something I knew. It's what I watched, right? Growing up, all those things. So I'm like, fuck, I'll try that thing. And went into it. This guy can do it.
Yeah, this fucker can do it. I can do that shit. No, but that's just kind of what I watched, what the, I guess, related to. And then anyway, fell in love with theater and then started studying theater and psychology and just ran from there. Wow, which is one of the things.
So I was like 18, 19, and yeah, just stuck with that. Well, it's funny, because you are such a sort of actor's actor, too, you know what I mean? Like you've got like- Very natural. Yeah, very natural, and you've got this thing, you're very serious and you can tell that you take your craft really seriously
and that you're very, you know, everything's well thought out, nothing's by mistake, you're not just hoping to get lucky in a take. You know what I mean? Yeah, and so it's funny that it kind of came to you later because it seems like it's really such a, it comes so naturally. Well, I mean, that just comes,
I think that's the psychology sort of part of it. And you have to, I think there's a self-awareness and a confidence that, you know, that comes from doing stage. You see a lot of, when people are stage actors, they hold it in their body a bit more. They're not just doing a scene or a thing. They're kind of immersed in their body and spirit.
Because you have to do it for an hour and a half, two hours on stage, right? You have to really embody it longer than we do when we're doing television and film. Yeah, that's a good point. Was music something that was sort of pulling at you as well? Did you have to sort of make a decision with yourself whether you were gonna kind of put all your weight behind one or the other?
No, no, I never considered music as a career. It's always a form of therapy, artistic... A hobby? Yeah, well, that's so much a hobby. I don't really believe in hobbies. I feel like either do something or you don't. I don't have fucking time for hobbies. That's hysterical.
You know what I mean? Very good. I don't have time to just dip my toe in the water. I'm not taking a fucking bath here in life, right? Just dipping my toe in it. It's not happening. So, you're gonna do something, or yeah, yeah, you do it or you don't, right?
So... Yeah, Jason, you dumb fuck. Yeah, you're right. I didn't want to be a player of music, right? I didn't want to be a guitar player or a drummer, which I am those things, or a piano player. I don't have the time or patience, or even excellence or skill set to be able to do that.
What I did want to do is be able to play these instruments to compose, to have a form of expression. Music is a wonderful form to express. And it's wonderfully shared as well. You can't really share poetry so much as you can with music. It's more uniting in its experience. And so I love music for that. And that'll always be near and dear to me
and very important to me in my life. But I don't want some record label saying, you gotta do this, you gotta do that. I'm like, fuck off, or I have to do something. I do it for the purity of it for me and the expression of it for me. Do you have time to still play music with Sons of the Pioneers?
No, no, I just do stuff in the studio. Yeah, okay. Do stuff in the studio at this point. And like I did for the, from after the accident, I put together an EP of a collection of songs that were about the life, death, and recovery of this last sort of 16 months of my life or a collection of songs that were about the life, death and recovery of this last sort of 16 months of my life or a year of my life.
And I put out the seven songs on the anniversary of this year. Yeah, that's really heavy. I didn't know that. Yeah, I wanna hear about that. Yeah, me too. And can you talk a little bit about that? I mean, obviously we all heard the devastating news
when the accident happened, and then of course, that you sort of pulled through, and obviously pulled through with colors now, but what a time in your life, and could just walk us through that a little bit, if you could. Yeah, and I'd like to know just personally, to add it to that, is like, what do you,
it's a common question, I'm sure, but what do you see differently now that you're on the other side of it? We could've waited for him to answer the first one. I guess, yeah, I guess the answer to that is like. Yeah, no, don't start at the end like Sean's asking you to. Let's go with the beginning. Let's help Tracy out in Wisconsin
and tell her what you were doing and what happened. And action. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, look, it's probably one of the greatest things that's happened to me in my life. Yeah, wow. And it's not just because it happened to me, it happened to, well, we're talking about it now because you guys are aware of it.
And so there's a lot of people around this planet. It became a very personal experience that happened on my property. He's trying to save my nephew from getting ran over by this snow plow and snow cap. But it's turned into not such a private experience. I didn't know why. I was already on life support,
and while everybody else was getting, becoming aware of this incident. And then I wake up from it, and I'm like, why is everybody freaking out? I'm fine, I'm gonna get out of this hospital in two days, I'm walking out of here, speed's no problem. At least that's what the drugs are telling me. I must be as high as a kite thinking that, right?
But there's a unifying understanding of what was about to become knowledge of who I am as a man a brother a father and a person Not famous for what I did for a living, you know, I'm not Hawkeye anymore. I'm like, oh, this is Jeremy Renner He overcame this incident or is overcoming this incident and there's something really fucking gratifying about that Where that changed my life.
Because I never liked being a celebrity. I never liked being adored for, people call me a hot guy, whatever. But being known for who you are as a human is really fucking cool. Something you did completely on your own. I mean, obviously the help of all the medical staff. People treat you differently. They treat me differently now. They don't treat me like a fan of Hawkeye or whatever.
Here's an example. On March, like two months, three months after the accident, I took my daughter to the Magic Mountain in LA, right, in Valencia, to ride all these roller coasters. I got cleared with all my breaks. Go home and ride these things. But it was like, I had to take the little cart around, the little golf cart thing you have to drive around,
because I couldn't walk very far. I could maybe walk like 15, 20 feet. So I had to drive this car around. But everywhere I went, it wasn't like I was being quiet, or got it, you know? I was just being me. I had a boombox, I brought plastic music, I think I'm having a good time.
But I go up the line, right? They let me sort of go in the front of the line. But people were like, it was Rudy, like slow clapping. And like, we're glad you're okay, da, da. It was such like a wonderful camaraderie. Like normally that situation would be like, oh, let me take something from you, I deserve a selfie, I want this, I want this, touch me, whatever.
Now it's like much more, there's a level of like. Give. Yeah, it was. But you gave... That's a wonderful shift that happened. Yeah, I think that because you've given so many people so much pleasure through your art and through what you do, that that applause is thank you for that,
and we're so glad that the guy that we love is doing great. It's really cool. But also it's that feeling, just that getting that love, right? Feels so good. Yeah, it made me believe in goodness in people that I didn't fucking think existed. Yeah, I love that.
In a big, big way, right? Not just a group of people, and not just a couple people in my hometown or my neighborhood. This is like in a pretty global way that this is happening. I think people are, for the most part, people are good. I do. Yeah, I know, I believe that too.
I just don't think they're in the right situations to have that come out. You're right, but you had spent so much time being somewhat, I don't know if I'm using this word correctly, but somewhat objectified, you know, which is kind of baked into the cake. It's kind of, it's what we do. We all have public jobs,
and there's certainly nothing to be resentful about with that, but at your level, I'm sure you just saturated with you being sort of approached and acknowledged as an object and that there's a bit of an ownership from the audience because of that. And basically, I can understand that, but this was a different kind of acknowledgement.
It was, we're actually people, we're not looking at Jeremy as a commodity, we're looking at him as a human being, and we could have died just like he almost died. All right. Well, also they became allies. We were equals and they were my ally. They were like, it's everyone,
every thought or prayer, if you will, is something I actually needed. I needed everything to recover. Right, and on Instagram, when I saw you post that video of you running, it was like one day you were, the accident happened, and it seemed like a week later, but I'm sure it was six months or a year later, you're jogging uphill this steep driveway.
I was like, oh my God, I can't even do that and I didn't get hit by a snowmobile. Like, you know what I mean? Well, but hang on, Sean, what if we put like a stir fry thing right at the top of it? That's a good incentive. You'd get up that hill. Good incentive, I could make it.
Jeremy, you told me something at that dinner and I hope you're comfortable relaying it on this. It was a story about, you know, to sort of make it sort of the stupid description of it, basically seeing the light and how there is an absolute similarity, if not identical type of experience that is repeated around the world from people that get this close to death.
And the way you relate it to me was in a way that was so sort of encouraging about possibly what that moment is to the point where, and I don't want to put words in your mouth, but it sounded like you no longer have as much a fear of death as you did before. And after hearing that story, I too share, I'm not looking forward to that moment, but I'm not as fearful of it as I once was.
So to the extent you're comfortable, please. Yeah, for me, I think most people have, I have a different relationship with fear, first and foremost, because I worked on it every day, something I was afraid of for a decade. I just don't have a lot of fear in my life. I certainly wasn't afraid of death, but you can think that and believe that,
but it's a confirmation now. I found there's a lot of confirmations when you're tested to your limits and to your death and come back. There's a lot of confirmations that come out of that. Because I can believe in XYZ, but now there's proof in the pudding. Because I went there. And yeah, the exhilarating peace that happens in leaving this body,
with these limitations of spinning on this rock and this body with air and gravity, all this bullshit. But when you're, it's an exhilaration and it's such a freedom. So you remember feeling that? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Feeling that, really? Yeah, yeah, and I take that feeling with me all the time now. Wow.
It's, you can't really put a visual to it because there's no time, place, or space. It's all sort of a continuum. Every human, every exchange that's happened is happening simultaneously all at once. It kind of has a little bit of that arrival kind of vibe in it. Wow. It's like everything's all at once, and it's a little bit of that arrival kind of vibe in it. It's like everything's all at once
and it's a continuum and it's fucking exhilarating as it is peaceful at the same time. It's the greatest way I can describe it. Now you really did see the light that everybody talks about, yeah? It's a, yeah, to me it was, it's a sort of fibrous, like a muscle fibrous sort of connectivity to all, it's all energy, right?
So I guess that's the feeling that it is. I can't even say it's a visual, because I don't feel like any of that's there. Wow. Now, isn't it true that like, Will, you were telling me something about like, you can recreate, science has discovered a way to create that with certain drugs or circumstances where you can, that same, do you know what I'm talking about?
Like that same light or that same thing. Will, were you trying to sell Sean something out of the back of your van at that moment? No, no, I was saying that if you go, you know where, well, there's a guy, J-Rock, I told you about. He's got that DMT hookup. And he's got that DMT, and if you...
Jay Rock. Jay Rock, he'd go for a weekend. He does a weekend if you take the 118 all the way to the UK. I knew a guy named Earthquake that would sell me some J-Bod. Oh, yeah. And we will be right back. When I say we get support from Helix, boy do I mean it. I get so much support from my mattress from Helix. It's amazing.
I sleep great. I have the Dusk Lux mattress. I've had it for a few years now and it is beautiful. It's like I get so excited when I climb into bed and I sink right into that beautiful mattress and it just whisks me right off to sleep every single time. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress than by sleeping on it in your own home.
Don't sleep on my mattress, sleep on your own Helix mattress. That's why they offer a 100 night trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty. So how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Well, their team created a Helix Sleep Quiz to help you find your perfect mattress in under two minutes.
And your mattress is shipped straight to your door, free of charge. I took the quiz and got matched with the Desk Lux, as I mentioned, because I wanted that perfect, not too soft, not too firm feel. It's perfect for me. It's like they read my mind. Helix is offering 30% off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com SmartList. That's helixsleep.com SmartList. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With Helix, better sleep starts now. We get support from State Farm. Nothing feels better than a personal win, from finishing a home DIY project, hitting a workout PR, or even just taking your car in for that oil change. If you define it as a win, it calls for a celebration.
And who's cheering right beside you? State Farm. With the State Farm Personal Price Plan, you can create an affordable price just for you when you bundle home and auto. So celebrate by breaking out the confetti and those happy dance moves. Talk to a State Farm agent today to learn how you can bundle
and save with the personal price plan. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Prices are based on rating plans that vary by state. Coverage options are selected by the customer. Availability, amount of discounts and savings, and eligibility vary by state. We'd like to thank FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartList.
Summertime means baseball, the NBA Finals, and more, and you can bet it all on FanDuel. Right now, new customers get $200 in bonus bets with any winning $5 bet. That's $200 you can use to bet everything from the Finals MVP to who's going to hit one out of the park. I have a friend that uses FanDuel all the time and he raves about it and wins a lot, actually. Visit FanDuel.com slash SmartList and add a big win to your summer bucket list. FanDuel, America's number one sports book. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer.
SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar. Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds, new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audiobooks, podcasts,
and originals that members can listen to all they want with more added all the time. Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time. There's more to imagine when you listen. Right now I am about to listen to Survive the Night by Riley Sager. It's a thriller that's a real page-turner that's all I want to say about it. I don't want to give anything away but it's
really really good. As an Audible member you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try Audible free for 30 days.
Audible.com slash smartless. And back to the show. Jeremy, in all seriousness, you know, that is, thank you for sharing that. Yeah, that's really fascinating. Because that reminded me of some of the specifics of what you were saying there. And it is, you know, I don't know if encouraging
is the right word, but it does confirm for me some of the things I hope that moment is. Well, you have to understand too, this, right? Your body, like the accident, right? It could be the most excruciating pain that someone could go through, right? There's 38 broken bones, my eyeballs out of my head, I'm looking at my eye, I'm looking at my twisted legs,
and all these things, but I'm like, the pain is like really not that bad, your body kind of shuts it down, it's like overload, right? It's just a small part in the front of your brain where you feel pain, right? So you can kind of control that as well. And so it's interesting, fuck I got lost because I got so many issues from that accident in my brain,
I get a little sad track. Well so the pain is overwhelming, but the brain then has, it shuts that down, but it is also still working and has an opportunity to experience the other stuff that you're going through, which it sounds like this was the big thing that it chose to deal with, which was this opportunity to transition to whatever
happens after the body stops working anymore, and you're sort of experiencing what that moment is. And do you remember having a decision to make? Were you in control of whether you were going to go forward or return back? I mean, I was in control of my breath. And that's all I had to focus on, because if you can't breathe,
then nothing else is gonna matter. So I had to focus on exhaling, so I could then inhale, and I had a popped lung and all this stuff I didn't know. And the thing's still on top of you right then, right? No, I was, it rolled completely over me. And then it, yeah. Wow. Yeah, it was brutal.
Right. But, yeah, just conscious breath. Conscious breath was pretty important. And, you know, like you said, there's nothing to freaking worry about at the end of the day, you know, and I can confirm that. We all have something to look forward to. Whether we use God to get there, right, or whatever it is,
but it's something to look forward to and it's blissful and it's beautiful and there's accountability and responsibility that comes along with it and you take it all with you, man. Everything, everything. You're connected, you're connected all the time to all you want to be connected to. To everyone on this planet.
Yeah, yeah, it is all one thing, it's no fucking joke. It's all energy. Jeremy, did you have, I mean, this shift in perspective is remarkable, I'm sure, and I can see the weight of it, and I can't appreciate it the way that you can, obviously, but has this, I imagine, and you kind of touched on it, but talk a little bit about what that shift in perspective has done for you in practical terms on a day-to-day level? Yeah, I think the clarity. I think everyone is conspiring to keep my life lean and keep the white noise out.
I feel that life is a lot easier, even though on paper it's much more difficult to spend hours just so I can walk every day. You know, I have to do all this stuff. Still? Yeah, yeah, yeah. But I'm in good shape, but I don't have pain. I have to do just a bunch of stuff, and who cares? I'm still walking, right?
They told me I wasn't gonna walk, but I think my life being so lean, and it's been the best gift. Yeah, imagine you don't sweat the small stuff anymore. No, yeah, it wasn't really a guy that did, but again, it's one of those sort of confirmation kind of things. It's like the things that were working for me before,
I really just doubled down on. And whether it's spending time with those, it's like you, Jason, how much you love your family and want to spend time with your family, and whatever it is, you just do the things that you love to do. And I was really terrible at doing stuff for myself and asking for help.
Now I'm really good at asking for help because Jesus Christ, I needed all the help I can get. And then so I have no problem asking for help and I spend so much time on myself and self care. I'm like, look, I've got hydrogen water, I've got all these shots, I've got liposomal, even right here. I've got all this stuff,
I'm doing so many good things for my body. So I honor this vessel that I'm living in right now. Like life is just wonderful, because again, it's so clean and simple. And I love that. Sean feels the same. Sean, you got a lot of help from the Frito Lay Company. They do a lot of work with you.
Well, they know what I need. They make the bags a little bit easier to open nowadays. The McConnell Ice Cream Company also is one of your guys. Haagen-Dazs, Haagen-Dazs. Haagen-Dazs, sure. But Jerry, you know what? The whole thing, such an inspiration to never give up, to keep going, to take the worst things in life
that come after you when you come out on top. All of it, I mean, really, I saw that video, I was like, God, if he can come through that, I gotta get off my ass and just take better self off my vessel. Well, you will one day. Jeremy, talk a little bit, if you will, about, because you kind of mentioned it about this creative,
this sort of, we're all connected the the sort of Collective consciousness that is a lot more sort of real and visceral than we think and rather just an idea and your relationship with Maybe God even or higher power or whatever that is Where do you land on all that stuff and you guys too? I don't know Yeah, well my dad is a theologist, and so I studied all religions growing up. Oh wow, that's cool, I love that. I've been in tents with snakes, and I've been in all of them, studied them all.
And I found them all interesting. Organized religions never end up being my bag, but I think because of it. But I do believe that in anything that, believe in anything that makes you a better person, a more thoughtful person, a conscious person, I think that's great. So I've got no problems with religion in general. So I land, look, at some point during my recovery, I know I had to give up my body to the EMTs and the people when I was on the ice
for 45 minutes, right? Just struggling for my next breath and that's where I passed and they had to jam a needle in my chest and do all that stuff, inflate my lung. I gave myself up to them to just have to work on whatever they had to do to get me to survive. But I think there's all because also those I knew the guy that that was working on me and he called one of my best friends
who's a firefighter he says you're gonna want to get to the hospital because I just took off in a med effect flight to the to the hospital and he called my buddy who's a firefighter he's like I just worked on Jeremy Dada's want to see we did the best we could and he's like there's no way this worker's gonna make it. So he went to the hospital, said he wanted to get there, go be with his sister, whatever. And you know, when those guys say, you don't have a chance, right?
So I think there's some fucking divine intervention is the shortest. I don't know what it is, guys. I don't know, there is no answer to that. I think the divine intervention is fucking thoughts and prayers, if you will, from others. It's the will of those doctors, they're like, look at this motherfucker.
We're gonna work extra hard. Or die, whatever the, like, my will, right? My will is fucking, it's strong, let me just say that. And I think there's others, that energy goes into others that would help, all those EMTs and the firefighters that were there saving my ass, and Sheriff Department, all those guys that were there to save my ass, right?
All connected. Yeah, it's all connected, man. So as hard as I was working, I think that bleeds into others and they worked harder, and I think every flower that came in, every nurse that changed a bit, whatever the heck it is, man, that's all like love and all working towards surviving. And let that be divine, the collective divinity of humans, right, which I think is fucking brilliant and good,
the energy of human. Yes, I agree. And I think that's what the divine intervention is, ultimately. I don't think it's what the divine intervention is, ultimately. I don't think it's some god or some guy coming down on a carpet or whatever. It's none of these kind of things. I just think it's an energetic thing. And I can define it as love. That's maybe what divine intervention is for me.
That helps me survive. I think that fucking continues. Us just sitting here talking about it, I'm sure thoughts of thoughts are swirling in all of our heads as we're talking, right? Yeah, you make me think about what an incredible opportunity everybody has to plug into that network of connectivity. 100%, yes.
Where it is available to all of us, and it is labeled different things at different times. Sometimes it's love, sometimes it's religion, sometimes it's collaboration, whatever you want to call it. But we're all here and we all kind of come from the same thing. And that whole sort of one plus one makes three equation is again, it's available to us all. And sometimes I have days where I've got the courage
to plug into it and leave myself open to the input from other people. And some days I don't, you know? And the days that I do have that courage and that openness and that vulnerability and that humanity sort of draw, those days are great for me. And things, you just feel like you're in a slot
and shit just happens. You get the parking spot in front of the building you're going to, you make the green light, like all of that silly stuff, but I don't think that's coincidence. I think those are the days when you're really open to this community. You know, I agree.
But JB, there's also the idea, there's an idea to, first of all, I love plugging into a slot, but I would say, that's just OCD, but I would say this, I would say, you know, those days when it also, for me anyway, my experience is, it's really important to, whatever energy I'm putting out there, whatever I'm putting in the world, I'm gonna get back.
And what you were saying, like, fighting the open spot or whatever, if I'm driving on the highway, or if I'm driving around Los Angeles, I'm going, look at this asshole and fuck this guy, and whatever, every asshole is gonna show up in my experience. But if I surrender, and there's a lot of surrender
in what you're talking about, Jeremy, throughout everything you've said, there's a lot of surrender and giving up. And if I surrender and go, I'm not in that much of a rush. It's not gonna make that much, let the guy go ahead of me. And then you know what starts happening? Everything starts opening up. Because if I keep going fuck, fuck, fuck,
and eventually somebody's giving me the finger on the 405. Guaranteed, that's a lock. But if I start just opening up and just going, taking my foot off the gas and surrendering, and that goes for every aspect of my life. I find it all the time. I try to do it in little things, it's not easy. I call it like sort of spiritual calisthenics.
Just doing things, I'm just putting out good vibes as much as I can. Sometimes I'll just show up to your house and give you the finger, like when you answer the door. Yeah, one time Shum woke me up in the middle of the night, shaking me, I opened my eyes, and he was just giving me the finger, and he said, fuck you.
Yeah, that's helpful. I love that visual. But you know what I mean? I think that there's a lot to that, and I'm feeling like the energy, again, not to sound too fricking hokey, people are gonna be like, hey, but you can feel it. You've got this kind of vibe that you're putting out there
which is sort of a loving positive vibe. So it's no surprise that that's what showed up in your experience. And now does that translate into like how you approach, sorry to get back to this stuff, but how you approach work now? Or is it still the same? Well, I think it's, I was very terrified, you know, I was very terrified to get,
because I'm, to do like fucking fiction? I mean, I'm still trying to live in reality. I'm trying to live, right? So it was, it was a hard line for me to cross. Because shit got real and then your job is to be fake. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's like, wow, man. It was a big stretch.
It was very, very challenging for me, mentally, to get over that hump. And I still struggle with it sometimes. It was a big stretch. It was very challenging for me mentally to get over that hump. And I still struggle with it sometimes. I don't take it super seriously. I'm in a character that I can do very well and I know the show very well, so it was easy for me to kind of slide back into it.
But if it was a very challenging role, I couldn't have taken it. Not challenging in the sense of, because this movie, the show's challenging, but it's that, you know, if I had to go play Dahmer or something, like something so far from me. Like the spiritual space. Yeah, I just don't have the energy for it.
I don't have the fuel. I have so much fuel to put into like this reality, this body, all this stuff. I can't just go play make believe right now. Because it takes a lot of time to get right here every day, just so I can have a positive thought, so I can progress, so I can always keep growing. Well, listen to me, you need to write books, because I'd read...
I am writing one right now, actually. Oh, you are? I'm writing one right now, and I'm going to spend the whole summer doing it. Hopefully I can get it out Maybe by the year's end or beginning next year amazing but you know having experiences like this, you know, I speak to a lot of different people but Always something new comes out and always learn something new in in the process and the questions Yeah, and it seems like you really light up when you talk about this
Which again like you said is it's part of the gift of that happening. Yeah, it's a wonderful gift. You said it was the best thing that's ever happened to you. Yeah, yeah, it's wonderful gifts. And it'll be, you know, something Palson will have with you guys forever, right? Our exchanges will always have a basis of this, a wink to the knowingness of something, right? And we can laugh at all the jokes we want
and fart and do all, you know, go play golf terribly, and whatever it is, but we know there's an underlying current of a connectivity to something. Yes. And it's something beautiful about it. Yeah, and you've had that experience firsthand, and you have very, very generously shared that
with not only us, but the people listening. And if they're like me, they will hold onto it forever. Because our mortality is something that we can kind of compartmentalize for a while, but if you're on the second half, like us guys are, it starts to become a little bit more a part of your thinking day to day. And you've given me a lot more comfort
for what the inevitable is. And I really, really appreciate that. Yeah, man. Yeah, and Jeremy, I really mean it. It sounds cheesy to say it, but thanks for the lessons today. And I mean that. I'm like, wow, I mean, all the stuff
that you're talking about, I'm now gonna be, like you said, I'm gonna be thinking about it for the rest of my life. Because there's, people say the same things in different ways, but they don't land all the stuff that you're talking about, I'm now gonna be, like you said, I'm gonna be thinking about it for the rest of my life. Because people say the same things in different ways, but they don't land all the time. And a lot of the stuff you said today really landed. Well, thanks, brother. That just means it's just a shared experience then.
Right, this is not a lesson. These are just shared experiences. Yeah, I love this sort of the shift in perspective. It's pretty amazing. And as somebody once said, it's really hard to get a new perspective if you can't get perspective. Like it's like if you can't just allow yourself
to have it, it's hard to get it. And anyway, I really feel it from you, man. It's fucking awesome. And before you go, please do another, do a sequel to Arrival, please. Yeah. It's called Departure. Yeah. That's called Departure.
That's really funny. Jeremy, thank you so, so much for your time today and your level of transparency with what your experience has been. It's been a real gift, so thank you, buddy. Yeah, man. I love you guys, man. Appreciate the time. Love you too, Jeremy. You too, brother. Well done, man. Fucking killer. Thanks, pal. Hope I see you soon, buddy. Yeah, man, I love you guys, man. Appreciate the time. Love you too, Jeremy. You too, brother. Well done, man. Fucking killer.
Thanks, pal. Hope I see you soon, pal. Yes, sir. Thanks, Jeremy. Have a good day. See you, man. Thank you, dude. All right, man, man. Bye, buddy. See you, guys.
Well, I hope... Enlightening. Yeah, I hope that story... I mean, the whole interview was really enjoyable, but man, I just can't tell you how I have held on to that, what he told me at dinner, and I'm so appreciative that he shared it with all of us today, because if you're like me,
it's kind of, it's just sort of a nice thing to have in your back, you're in your pocket that it might not. If you see that train coming. Well, I mean, it's gonna happen to all of us. Everything that's born lives to, or what is it, everything that lives was born to die, something like that, I think it's a Pink Floyd line,
but we're all going. And what is that moment like? I hope it's not terrible, I hope it's not sad, I hope it's not painful, it sounds like it's not. Yeah. Shit. Yeah, shit. I got some fucking bad.
I'm ready. Okay, I know how both you guys die. What? Uh-oh, what, how do you know? Is it painful? It's interesting, it is a little painful. How do you know this? Have you ever seen, okay, have you, because I just did, okay, you remember the movie,
you know that story about that Chilean rugby team? Sure, sure, yeah. So you guys are, fuck, it's so crazy. Anyway, you guys end up shit-racked. You and Sean, the two of you. Shit-racked? Fucking Sean eats you, dude. What?
Does he season me at all? You guys get shit-wrecked and it's just the two of you in a big container of mayo. But if I eat Jason, well, how do I die? Well, you die because... But if I eat Jason will how do I die well Because no because yeah, because it's he's so malnourished He's still malnourished That it that it ends up poisoning you Nutritional value at all to my body body goes into a shock. So jokes on me.
Well, I just want to say about Jerry, he was so great. He's a perfect example of following your heart and good things happen, period. You know? Just like, I love that. He's such a good guy. Yeah, he really is. And honestly, it is true. When you hear him, this is what we've talked about before,
which is he's clearly had a shift in like, what validates him as a person is not about what he does for a living, but who he is as a person. And he can separate those things. And it's so true, and because it's so easy, especially doing what we do, to peg your feeling of success or success as a human being to what you do. And that that is your wealth. Yeah, what he's saying.
No, no, the wealth is the... And it's not, it's not. It's the living, it's the relationships that you have with other people. And he said that that connection with other people is really the thing that got him through. So that's pretty amazing. Well, that was a nice episode, y'all.
Yeah, really nice. It was real nice. I'm sorry to learn that my life comes to an end with Sean taking a big byeeeeee out of me. Byeeeeee! Byeeeeee! Smart. Lens.
Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. Lens. Smart. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. SmartLess
If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. It's all a lighthearted nightmare on our podcast, Morbid. We're your hosts. I'm Alina Urquhart. And I'm Ash Kelly. And our show is part true crime, part spooky, Morbid. We're your hosts, I'm Alina Urquhart. And I'm Ash Kelly. And our show is part true crime, part spooky, and part comedy. The stories we cover are well researched.
He claimed and confessed to officially killing up to 28 people. With a touch of humor. I just like to go ahead and say that if there's no band called Malevolent Deity, that is pretty great. A dash of sarcasm and just garnished a bit with a little bit of cursing. This mother-f***er lied. Like a liar. Like a liar. And if you're a weirdo like us and love to cozy up to a creepy tale of the paranormal.
Or you love to hop in the way back machine and dissect the details of some of history's most notorious crimes. You should tune in to our podcast, Morbid. Follow Morbid on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can tune in to our podcast, Morbid. Follow Morbid on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts.
You can listen to episodes early and ad free by joining Wondery Plus and the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.